you're in a film half magic yeah a film
that is this directed by Heather great
friend my very good friend Heather
Graham wrote and directed it's her first
movie and I do a part in it I didn't
realize you guys were close friends we
are we're really close girlfriends for
years yeah we met years ago when she
can't even hosted Saturday Night Live
we've just been friends ever since you
know she was on the show recently and
she was terrific as she hadn't been on
in a while and she came back on the show
and she was great she was she told me
that she was like oh my god I had so
much fun in Conan's show and she was
like Conan told me that I'm his
celebrity crush and I was like really
and she sent me is that true supposed to
sort of be a confidential thing no I had
I you know when I first met Heather
Graham and she came on the show for the
first time I was like he-man I homina oh
my god you know I've always had a
special place in my heart for but of
course happily married 16 years now why
would we why would we bring up a crush
on television in front of everyone
reciprocate the feelings you know what
you said about I wish we were both
holding pillows and it was at night and
we were having a sleepover oh you're
like a teenage girl yes okay so anyway
in so many ways
so what so what she said what she was
like I think he's so cute
yeah total a total hunk but she's that
okay okay you get her this no you give
her this note I'll wait over by the yeah
he would go on a date with you if you
weren't married if you weren't married
yeah since I'm so happily married she
thinks you're like really cool okay this
is just funny that's pretty Prince okay
[Applause]
you